c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
serait il est bien mais surtout ce 24ème
ce soir cet accord entre londres et
kigali il consiste à renvoyer des
demandeurs d'asile au rwanda pour
décourager les migrants clandestins de
traverser illégalement la manche les
traversées qui ont atteint des records
en 2021 ce soir nous évoquons le sort de
joël aïvo cela fera un an ce vendredi
que opposant béninois est en prison
condamné à 10 ans de détention pour
blanchiment de capitaux et atteinte à la
sûreté de l'état nous avions interrogé
son avocat fatiou ousmane extrait à
suivre
l'inquiétude demeure en afrique du sud
après les intempéries qui ont fait plus
de trois cent quarante et un morts le
pays attend de nouvelles précipitations
alors que le dit dans des inondations ne
cesse de s'alourdir l'état de
catastrophe a été déclaré les détails
dans ce journal
c'est la nouvelle idée folle de boris
johnson et elle s'est concrétisée en un
accord historique entre le rwanda et le
royaume-uni le premier ministre
britannique a obtenu les personnes
arrivant au royaume-uni clandestinement
soit automatiquement envoyées au rwanda
dont elle pourrait faire leur demande
d'asile objectif décourager les migrants
clandestins a traversé la manche les
précisions de camille nédélec
les conservateurs avaient fait campagne
sur la baisse de l'immigration pourtant
depuis des mois les arrivées clandestine
ne cesse d'augmenter le gouvernement
britannique a trouvé une solution
controversée un plus de 6000 km ce jeudi
la ministre de l'intérieur prédit vettel
a signé un accord avec kigali et toutes
personnes arrivées illégalement depuis
le 1er janvier pourrait être localisée
au rwanda
cette initiative innovante motivée par
notre approche humanitaire commune est
rendue possible par les libertés liés au
brésil fournira des voix d'asile sur est
légal tout en perturbant le modèle
économique des gangs de passeurs
cet accord pourrait concerner des
dizaines de milliers de personnes quel
que soit leur origine en échange le
royaume unis s'engagent à verser au
rwanda la somme de 144 millions d'euros
pour assurer le traitement des dossiers
et accueillir les demandeurs d'asile
dans des centres comme celui ci de son
côté kigali se dit prêt à accueillir de
manière permanente les personnes qui le
souhaitent
de nombreux rwandais savent ce que c'est
que d'être déplacés et notre approche de
la migration et de l'asile sont marqués
par ces expériences
par une seconde scène considèrent leur
mandat comme un modèle de sécurité
malgré son bilan en matière de droits de
l'homme
la signature de cet accord n'a pas tardé
à faire réagir l'opposition britannique
mais également les ong
c'est une politique inhumaine
irréalisable et très coûteuses qui ne
devrait même pas être nous ne devrions
même pas en parler
l'onu a également dénoncé cet accord
avec la plus grande fermeté indiquant
qu'il était contraire à la lettre et à
l'esprit de la convention sur les
réfugiés
ce vendredi cela fera un an que
l'opposant béninois joël aïvo est en
prison il avait été condamné à 10 ans de
détention le professeur de droit
constitutionnel dont la candidature à la
présidentielle de 2000 21 n'avaient pas
été validées a été reconnu coupable de
blanchiment de capitaux et d'atteinte à
la sûreté de l'état ce soir nous sommes
en direct avec son avocat maître fat
youthman bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en sommes bien accueillis alors tout
d'abord calé l'état d'esprit de joël
aïvo après un an de détention
savez quand vous êtes face à certaines
situations d'injustice prince des
injustices aussi flagrante il ya deux
façons de réagir la première se laisser
écraser par le désespoir et le le
sentiment d'avoir été mal jugé et la
seconde c'est celle qui a qui mène fait
souvent celle de frédéric jouët à ibos
et de se renforcer dans ces conditions
et de se conforter dans ce qu'on croit
et dans le combat qui est le sien celui
pour le
rétablissement de la démocratie au ghana
et celui pour le retour d'un bénin comme
celui que les biennois ont connu depuis
les années 90 et qui malheureusement
n'est plus le cas depuis 2010 16 ou le
régime de batista l'eau et tout pouvoir
et si vous le permettez on en parlera
dans quelques minutes ce procès n'était
pas au réel pensais c'était une insulte
à la démocratie c'est une insulte à la
justice et aux droits c'est la raison
pour laquelle fait dès que je vais les
niveaux victime d'une injustice grave se
retrouve aujourd'hui dans une zone
emprisonnement pour dix années ont des
faits dont on a démontré devant la
clayette qui est la cour de répression
des infractions économiques et de
terrorisme qu'elle n'avait jamais été
caractérisée qu'en plus les mises en
cause des principaux mis en cause a
déclaré indique exceptionnel et john
lithgow n'avait jamais été impliqué dans
le moindre qu'ils aient pu conduire à
une moindre culpabilité alors justement
considérez vous que votre client est un
prisonnier pour les politiques ou
simplement à un délinquant en col blanc
lui en jeu lui dit que c'est un
acharnement politique ans et plus qu'on
acharnement politique la grille est je
le rappelle qui est une attitude tienne
juridiction d'exception créée il ya
seulement quelques quatre années par le
régime en place à coup de mou à eux
clairement été crié pour être
l'instrument de la répression politique
des opposants de patrice talon c'est la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs dans sa
première mouture là pour africaine des
droits de l'homme et des peuples avaient
retoqué la loi qui aime avoir porté sa
création et avait fait en sorte que
certaines évolutions élus nonobstant ces
évolutions
les juges nommés 7 dans cette
juridiction sont sous la direction la
supervision ya même la tutelle immédiate
des digues des puissants du moment ce
qui a entraîné une série d'inédits
d'erreur de d'errements dans la
procédure qui ont conduit à une
condamnation qui elle même de toute
façon était écrite dès lors que sur vos
ondes france 24 et sur les antennes de
rfi pas triste alors avait publiquement
fait le procès de frédérique bel album
et de réckya madougou accusant l'une de
porter des valises d'argent ou irlandais
la campagne électorale et l'autre de
menacer le déroulement de l'élection
présidentielle alors que le la
candidature de wade joël aïvo était
annoncé depuis quelques semaines et
qu'il a avancé sans masque sur un
terrain politique volant challenge et
patrice talon et le confronter à l'arrêt
des paiements alors justement est-ce que
le sort de joseph joël aïvo et est lié à
celui de réckya madougou que vous venez
de citer on s'est dit si ces deux
affaires totalement distinctes c'est de
ces deux situations différentes la seule
le seul point commun ces deux affaires
c'est qu'elles ont ciblé deux opposants
politiques dont il était clairement
indiqué que citer les principaux
challengers de patrice talon c'est la
raison pour laquelle patrice talon a
fait d'une pierre deux coups dans un
premier temps madame reckya madougou le
6 mars de mémoire et dans un second
temps fédérer jouer à la ebook tous les
deux ont été interpellés dans des
conditions qui renvoie à non pas une
interpellation en bonne et due forme par
des forces de police mais à des méthodes
de voyou avec des interpellations en
pleine circulation
sans convocation préalable on est dans
un kidnapping politique claire alors y
at il une chance que votre client soit
grâciée ou amitié par exemple mais
celui-ci croyez voir
je ne crois que ce que je vois ce que je
vois c'est que pour l'instant le régime
en place n'a offert aucun gage
d'ouverture de
d'apaisement ce que je vois c'est qu'au
contraire le tour de vis ce qui est
annoncé et qui va se concrétiser dans
quelques mois avec l'édition
législatives de
2003 est en train d'être mises en place
et que rien mais alors rien du tout nous
laisse penser que la situation politique
va s'apaiser j'ai bon espoir que à un
moment ou à un autre les choses se
détendent et que ayant réussi à leur
tour de force les dirigeants actuels
pense qu'en face le pays mme élite alors
qu'il est confronté à des situations de
terrorisme le pays que ce pays mérite
l'apaisement et le rassemblement de tous
ses fils je rappelle que le père de deux
enfants et que ces étudiants sont privés
d'un homme de valeur qui était également
expert des nations unies pour les
questions des droits de l'homme merci
beaucoup aux maîtres mathieu ousmane je
rappelle que vous êtes l'avocat de joël
aïvo opposant un béninois a condamné à
10 ans prison merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et on continue à
parler des intempéries en afrique du sud
le bilan continue d'augmenter on recense
désormais au moins 3 141 morts il s'agit
des pires inondations vécu dans le pays
l'état de catastrophe a été déclarée
lieu de samuel
alors que la nuit tombe c'est sud
africains viennent devant ce foyer
communautaire avec l'espoir d'y trouver
refuge tout près d'eux d'urban ils sont
nombreux à venir inscrire leur nom sur
ce registre afin de passer la nuit ici
beaucoup ont tout perdu après les
inondations meurtrières qui ont frappé
la région
pendant 30 minutes de l'eau arrivait
arriver arrive et puis après ça j'ai
commencé à courir là où il n'y avait pas
d'eau sur le toit
puis l'eau est arrivé au dessus de ma
chambre le toit s'est effondré et des
murs se sont écroulés
des milliers d'habitants ont vu leurs
maisons complètement détruite comme ici
les plus torrentielles ont provoqué
d'immenses glissements de terrain de
nombreux ponts se sont effondrés et
beaucoup de routes sont désormais
impraticable le président cyril
ramaphosa est venu en personne constater
les dégâts et promettre l'aide du
gouvernement
nous allons visiter d'autres lieux qui
ont été touchées par les inondations
pour se rendre compte des dégâts afin de
mesurer l'aide nécessaire nous vous
remercions de nous avoir laissés nous
rendre compte par nous mêmes de ce qui
s'est passé et d'avoir pu nous
entretenir avec vous
les autorités ont lancé une mise en
garde face aux risques de nouvelles
intempéries dans les prochains jours des
précipitations qui pourraient provoquer
de nouvelles inondations
en somalie après plus d'un an de crise
politique les députés ont enfin prêté
serment aujourd'hui leur élection est
prévue début janvier 2021 n'a pas pu se
tenir en raison de problèmes logistiques
et sécuritaires le scrutin aurait dû
aboutir à la nomination d'un nouveau
président depuis le 8 février 2021 le
président mohammad à abdoulaye sy
mohammad est en poste malgré
l'expiration de son mandat ce qui a fait
plonger le pays dans une crise politique
les précisions de notre correspondant
dans la région bastien renouil
la prestation serment des députés s'est
déroulée au sein de l'aéroport de
mogadiscio
là où se trouve la base de l'union
africaine et les institutions onusiennes
l'un des rares endroits de la capitale
somalienne à être suffisamment protégé
pour pouvoir accueillir sur tous ces
leaders politiques et éviter une attaque
du groupe terroriste islamiste al shabab
qui menace régulièrement le processus
électoral et qui contrôle une très
grande partie du pays sur les 2 175
députés qui doivent composer le
parlement somalien seul 236 ont déjà été
élus il ya encore des élections qui
doivent se tenir pour nombre d'entre eux
qui ont été déplacés pour des raisons
d'organisation ou encore de sécurité et
cela après de longs mois de processus
électoral puisque l'élection a commencé
au mois de novembre 2021 plusieurs mois
après la fin de mandat du président
pharma jo cette élection pour élire les
membres de la maison du peuple c'est le
nom du parlement somalien n'a en réalité
pas mobiliser le peuple puisque le
peuple somalien n'a pas le droit de
voter pour cette élection contrairement
aux promesses de campagne du président
farmad jour en 2017 le peuple somalien
n'a pas pu se déplacer aux urnes
notamment pour des raisons sécuritaires
et ce sont donc les chefs de clans les
chefs traditionnels somaliens qui ont
élu les députés un petit peu plus de
mille votants et se sont ensuite ces
députés qui choisiront le nouveau
président mais voilà pour l'instant il
n'y a pas de date il faut encore que les
députés manquant souhaité lui pour que
l'ensemble du parlement puisse choisir
le nouveau président
les députés ivoiriens ont examiné hier
le l'agenda législatif de ces prochains
mois il a été question d'une proposition
de loi qui va sans doute faire débat
elle vise à poser une limite d'âge pour
les candidats à la magistrature suprême
le président ouattara il serait lui-même
favorable pourtant elle le
disqualifierait pour la prochaine
présidentielle y compris deux autres
poids lourds de la politique ivoirienne
laurent gbagbo et henri konan-bédié la
correspondance à abidjan de samuel
bernard
alassane ouattara à 91 ans laurent
gbagbo en a 76 et henri konan-bédié en à
87,6 cette loi déposé par un député
indépendant été voté ils seraient tous
écartés de la prochaine élection
présidentielle alors elle a été cette
loi était votée le 4 avril dernier son
vote cependant n'est pas pour tout de
suite telle loi n'a pas été inscrite
dans les discussions le semestre il va
falloir attendre août pour connaître la
date à laquelle ce texte sera débattu la
raison évoquée c'est qu'avant d'être
inscrit au calendrier législatif le
texte peut être analysée par le
président alassane ouattara lui même qui
émettra des observations le député à
l'origine de la loi à qui nous avons
parlé ne sais pas si le chef de l'état
soutiendra son projet tout dépendra en
fait donc de ces fameuses observations
du président qui feront office de
consigne de vote pour la majorité alors
pourquoi une telle loi serait telle
soutenu par le gouvernement actuel elle
pourrait en fait permettre au parti au
pouvoir le rhdp d'avoir un avantage aux
prochaines élections alors que le
président alassane ouattara aura
préparer la transmission du flambeau au
sein de 100 parts de son parti les
autres partis eux pourraient se retrouvé
empêtré dans des guerres de succession
côté opposition pour le moment le parti
d'henri konan bédié le pdci ne se
prononce pas trop tôt selon eux quant à
laurent gbagbo il avait critiqué il ya
quelques mois une idée démodé en
invitant à regarder du côté des états
unis
pays présidé par joe biden qui à 79 ans
je souhaite que nos deux pays reprennent
ensemble la voie d'une relation apaisée
et puissent regarder vers l'avenir
déclarations du chef de la diplomatie
française jean yves le drian il était à
alger ce mercredi il a été reçu par le
président des magic est bonne il a
également rencontré son homologue
algérien ramtane lamamra il a été
question de renforcer les relations
bilatérales et d'amorcer un
rapprochement après une brouille de plus
de deux mois
et puis toujours en algérie les adieux
du journal liberté à ses lecteurs avec
ces derniers cette dernière une merci et
au revoir le quotidien aura traversé les
turbulences du pays pendant 30 ans et
dans ses colonnes que le caricaturiste
ali dilem a pu exercer son talent et son
trait qui a commenté le quotidien des
algériens pendant des décennies voici
son dernier dessin dans libertés le
dernier bouclage
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci aux équipes en régie
merci à notre chef d'édition célia
karacena merci à nos correspondants sans
qui ce journal ne pourrait pas se faire
et merci à vous de nous être fidèles
[Musique]